our session today is on faith and
globalization and human rights and we
have today with us a guest miss Jonah
Donovan who describes herself as a
political theologian you can ask her
maybe to tell you a bit more but what a
political theologian does and who a
political theologian might be described
to be but certainly political theology
is engaged in teasing out political
implication of some of the major
theological theological concepts and she
has as you who know written quite
extensively on human rights in
particular about the emergence of the
human human rights in the history of
them she has taught at Oxford University
together with her husband also a moral
philosopher moral theologian and is
presently teaching at university of
edinburgh i will make a few comments and
then i will see the floor to mr. Darwin
now ever since nineteen forty eight
language of Human Rights has
increasingly spread around the globe and
some folks even think that human rights
language is the new moral code some have
even suggested that it is a new religion
and you already see it in that phrase a
kind of competition between old style
and new style religions that some
accounts at least that rights or
religion can can suggest but at the same
time the meaning of Human Rights is
deeply contested probably as deeply
contested as as ever some rights that
were affirmed by United Nations in 1948
would likely not be affirmed by the same
body today example right to choose one's
religion or change and in particular
change one's religion we've very
difficult to pass that now indeed some
scholars believe that
word given to vote today to know the
Declaration of Human Rights would not be
adopted so what's going on on the one
hand popularity men's popularity of
rights language on the other hand
increased contestation of human rights
and meaning of human rights is it
possible for human rights to serve as
such as a new global as a global moral
code well even if it were possible would
it be desirable for human rights to
serve as such and some of the articles
that we've read mr. Donovan's but also
to a certain degree also Charles
Taylor's question is right do we need to
look for something like an alternative
to human rights and in Taylors case it
is almost human rights expressive of
particular norms and it's these norms
actually they are binding globally and
our human rights our particular version
Western version of expressing some
globally binding norms right right to
life maybe way we express things but
commitment and obligation not to kill
maybe the norm that right to life is a
particular way of of expressing so at
any rate there is a sense of both
importance of the question and spread of
Human Rights a language at the same time
questions about understandings proper
understandings and agreements and those
and even of the possibility of
agreements on human rights rather than
on something like norms now human rights
if embraced are deemed to be universal
rights but this is one phrase right for
human rights but it might have and it
does have radically different often
radically different me
meanings example and you can see I think
some of that even in the texts for this
week I believe freedom of religion I
already indicated that Universal
Declaration human rights speaks
explicitly of the right to change one's
religious belief many would embrace the
idea of the freedom of religion rights
free exercise of religion but would
strenuously contest the idea that it
includes the right to change one's
religion different folks may give
different preferences to different set
of right I'm mindful say of the Cold War
discussions about human rights where
societies in the West tended to favor
negative rights which the states are
obliged to respect something like civil
civil rights political rights freedom of
expression for instance whereas Eastern
folks in the East to which my formal
country that no longer exists belong
deva slavia right emphasized very much a
positive rights which is sustained which
state was supposed to guarantee social
cultural economic rights like the right
of employment and dried off vacation and
you've got similar kinds of may be
differences in the between Islam and
West today if you take the text that we
read for today Tyreke Ramadan's you'll
see that most of the rights that he
affirms belong to those kinds of pot
with it but I've described here is a
positive positive rights whereas it's
rather thin on rights highly prized in
the in the West and this may be also an
indication of very different conception
of Rights right and to quote from
o'donovan text Western conception of
subjective rights may be proprietary
rights over his her spiritual or
corporal capabilities and acts that may
be one version more amenable right to
the negative
definition of rights or it may signal
something like entire Ramadan's case
entitlements kind of moral obligation
that certain other people have in order
to provide these benefits as far as it
is possible right something like right
to solidarity and how do you do how do
you understand this as a right strictly
speaking right so it's important to keep
in mind that what we mean by me invoke
human rights and debates across cultures
and religions also but I think I want to
draw your attention to and now by now
it's kind of a mantra already that I
they are just about every time in bulk
and that's the self social relations in
the good right and you can see it in
understanding of human rights how
alternative ways of understanding what
the self is what social relations are
and the good is how these are expressed
in o'donovan article you have its
tracing of the whole development
basically lining up the accounts of the
self social relations and the good with
politically as well as an economic
arrangements centered around the notion
of human human rights you can see
similar thing being expressed again in
freedom of religion freedom of exercise
of religion predominantly you have in
Muslim communities but also Jewish
communities until very recently I think
in the Catholic tradition as well self
is already divided defined by social
relations you're Catholic you jus you're
Muslim right and communities have a
stake in self being part of that network
of these relationships this particular
social relations freedom of choice I
think self here stands much more on its
own who is in the act of choosing
aligning itself with with with others
and belonging to a particular community
I think also our discussion with moon
abu sulaiman was very interested in in
this regard right you've got the
conception their of the self right
in her case of what it means to be a
female a self which was very much
inserted in almost like a cosmic account
of the world right men are and women are
like moon and and the Sun distinct roles
there are some natural ways in which men
and women behave community in this
particular case family is being highly
prized and because of that you kind of
curtail your own behavior of the scope
itself and have your own quote unquote
rights in the context of defined in the
context of the community it's very much
different than what most of you have
expressed in this discussion which is I
think you reflected very much a Western
understanding of Rights which is rights
defined precisely against the kinds of
communities of which she described
herself as belonging so that if anybody
wants to deviate quote unquote from that
they're quite able to do that and their
quote unquote going other way would be
precisely respected again a very
different understanding of who the self
is what the social relations are and
what the good is and let me make a few
comments also there briefly about
religion and rights in particular and
then I'll just invite mr. Donovan to
speak to us one way to understand
relationship between religion and rights
even if you embrace rights define is
subjective right is to describe them as
competing moral universe text which we
haven't read but we read last time
around ugh well faddle text on Human
Rights from Muslim perspective he says
well there's a tension between
conviction all system of religion and of
human rights and the question is which
of these two generalized and objectified
systems warrants deference and which
constitutes the ultimate frame of
reference which one trans wit which I
mean this is a very important discussion
and it's important discussion in the
whole context of globalization
and pluralistic social social spaces you
can understand them either is completely
competing or possibilities to understand
them as subordinated moral claims this
has been generally the tradition in
recent years of the Catholic Catholic
Church right you've got theology States
ultimate in general norms and human
rights reflection articulates specific
norms there to be subordinated to
general ones and generally people with
robust religious convictions if they've
embraced language of Rights this is
roughly how they have formulated this it
being the case I think that for most
religious people the religious world
views are the overarching once and
everything else has to kind of
subordinate itself to to that and
there's some folks who think that
they're these are competing but complete
entery kind of accounts of norms they
have imperfectly overlapping basis of
support in our culture and both can be
partly they're competitive but partly
they are overlapping now one more two
more comments about religion and human
rights the question that sometimes is
being raised is what it is that can
sufficiently justify respect for human
rights and even apart from justification
of human rights what can motivate people
actually to respect rights rather than
fight simply for their own rights but
take on the respect of human rights as a
moral cause respect and struggle for
rights of others there are folks who
argue
some of you might be will not be
surprised that up in this class in this
class that actually the only theistic
grounding of Human Rights is possible
that is to say that you can't you can
advocate for human rights but you can't
give it sufficient justification for
those rights apart from some kind of
aphasic theistic not a taste great some
kind of a theistic framework and
generally the argument goes something
like like this well you can ground
rights in human capacities but they're
all sorts of folks who then fall out of
the range of those capacities that you
have specified as grounding human rights
something like rationality well they're
also to folks who either quite not
aren't quite yet there or have been
impaired insufficient significant ways
and our general intuition tells us that
we ought to ascribe rights if you
ascribe right so anybody anybody also to
them and there's no way in which you can
alternative way in which you can ascribe
rights right and therefore legitimize
right except through some form of
capacities and functions model and
that's inaudible and so Nicholas Walter
store who's very nice book I very much
like and it's called simply justice if
you want nice good reading I recommend
that netbook about 400 pages of it he
argues that the only way really that you
can justify human rights is by appeal to
some kind of relationship between human
beings and God and human beings in his
case he basically says God has affection
for human beings he likes them and
things that you like you invest in right
their investments in the things that you
like and that grind grounds human rights
in his example is this little teddy bear
of a child right so with whom the child
has been some
so much time and if you were to show
this teddy bear in a contest for the
beauty of teddy bears it may get the
last place right but if you ask the kid
which teddy bears skis or her favorite
it's the one with whom he or she has
slept over the many many months in many
many years it doesn't matter what
capacity is the teddy bear has right
what matters is attachment of the kid to
the to the time where something similar
Walter's love argues is the case in
relationship between God and human
beings quite apart from kind of
capacities one has its the attachment
and investment in this case of God in
human beings that grounds their human
human rights their intrinsic intrinsic
worth and also human rights let me stop
here and pass on the bottom to mr.
Donner